SPYING ON LIEUTENANT GENERAL
FLYNN.
IN A WORD, REPULSIVE.
30-YEAR VETERAN AND WAR HERO.
OUR TOP STORY TONIGHT, THAT IS
THE SAVORY OPENING FOR AMERICA
APPEARED WEEKS AGO, MILLIONS
OF BUSINESSES, THEY HAD TO SHUT
THEIR DOORS.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS STAYED AT
HOME.
LIFE WAS SERIOUSLY ALTERED FOR
EVERYONE IN THE COUNTRY.
WHY?
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THAT WAS THE GOAL.
THANKFULLY, TONIGHT, THE WORST
HAS BEEN AVOIDED.
REMEMBER THE DEVASTATING MODELS?
THANKFULLY, THEY WERE WRONG.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM HERE THEY’VE
ALL BEEN WRONG.
SOME MODELS PREDICTING AS MANY
AS TWO AND A HALF DEAD AMERICANS
COME A MILLION DEAD AMERICANS.
CITIES, STATES, COUNTIES, NEVER
EXPERIENCED THIS UNMANAGEABLE
SPIKE, THANK GOD ABOVE.
WE HIT THE APEX LIKE WE THOUGHT
WE WOULD.
IT LEVELED OFF, THEN DRAMATIC
DECLINE, THOSE CONTRACTING THE
DISEASE AND DYING FROM THIS
VIRUS, BARELY THAT IS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH FOR MANY DEMOCRATS AND
THOSE IN THE MOB.
THESE FEARMONGERS, THEY WANT ALL
AMERICANS WHO LANGUISH IN A
NATIONWIDE SHUTDOWN WITH NO END
IN SIGHT.
NOW THE MAYOR SAYS THE CITY WILL
NEVER REOPEN UNTIL THERE IS A
CURE.
DAVID PORTNOY POINTED OUT LAST
NIGHT WHAT IS NOW A VIRAL EPIC
GRANT.
WHEN DID FLATTEN THE CURVE TURN
INTO FINDING A CURE BEFORE WE
OPEN ANYTHING?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE L.A. MAYOR, WHERE NOT
OPENING THE CITY UNTIL WE FIND A
CURE?
WHAT?
PEOPLE HAVE JOBS WHO HAVE WORKED
THEIR WHOLE LEAP LIVE STUFF TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AND CREATE
A HAPPY LIVING.
THEY’RE JUST GOING TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS, THE GOING TO WAKE UP
WHENEVER THIS THING ENDS, AND
WHENEVER THE MAYOR SAY, OH, YOU
CAN GO BACK TO WORK.
WORK TO WHAT CUSTOMER COMPANIES
ARE GOING TO BE OUT OF BUSINESS.
>> Sean: DID A GREAT JOB ON
TUCKER’S SHOW.
POWERFUL MESSAGE.
L.A., IF YOU WANT TO WAIT UNTIL
THERE IS A CURE, THAT’S FINE BUT
DON’T EXPECT THE REST OF AMERICA
TO FUND YOUR SHELTER IN PLACE
UNTIL THERE IS A CURE DECISION.
YOU WANT TO MAKE THAT DECISION,
YOU THINK IT’S IN YOUR BEST
INTEREST, THAT’S ON YOU AND YOU
WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR ALL OF
THAT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE LAND OF
THE FREE, THE HOME OF THE BRAVE.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT GOING TO
COWER IN FEAR BUT WE WILL LEARN
THE LESSONS WE HAVE LEARNED THE
LAST FEW MONTHS.
WE DID THE LOCK DOWN, WE LISTEN
TO THE EXPERTS, EVEN THOSE THAT
WERE DEAD WRONG, EVERY MODEL
WRONG.
WE DID THANKFULLY FLATTEN THE
CURVE.
WE LEARNED SOME LESSONS FROM
SUCCESS AND SOME FROM FAILURE.
LET’S LOOK AT, FOR EXAMPLE,
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA, FLORIDA.
FLORIDA, THEY MOBILIZED THE
ENTIRE STATE, INCLUDING THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
EVERY STATE AGENCY TO SHIELD
NURSING HOMES AND RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES FROM THE VIRUS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
THE INCREASED TESTING, THEY
LITERALLY WRAP THEIR ARMS AROUND
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN FLORIDA.
AS A RESULT, FLORIDA’S DEATH
RATE REMAINED BELOW 2,000, EVEN
THOUGH THE STATE HAS AN ENORMOUS
ELDERLY POPULATION.
WELL, THE EXACT OPPOSITE
HAPPENED IN NEW YORK.
GOVERNOR CUOMO ON MARCH 25TH
MADE AN EGREGIOUS DECISION THAT
HAD DEADLY CONSEQUENCES IN
NEW YORK.
FIRST HE MET A LOT OF ERRORS,
AND HE IGNORED HIS 2015 HEALTH
INITIATIVE.
THEIR RECOMMENDATION, PEAK WEEK,
YOU’LL BE SHORT 15,783
VENTILATORS.
HE BOUGHT ZERO.
INSTEAD HE CAME UP WITH A PLAN
TO RATION THE 2,000 VENTILATORS
HE HAD.
THE SECOND BIG MISTAKE OCCURRED
WHEN CUOMO MANDATED, IF YOU
WANTED HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND
AZITHROMYCIN AND ZINC, YOU HAD
TO BE HOSPITALIZED TO GET IT.
IFIF YOU DIDN’T HAVE COVID WHEN
YOU WENT INCOME HE MIGHT’VE
GOTTEN IT WHEN YOU LEFT.
NOW THE THIRD AND WORST MISTAKE
CAME IN THE FORM OF THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER, TOOK THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE DUMBEST
HEALTH CARE "EXPERT" IN NEW YORK
NEW YORK, FORCING NURSING HOMES
AND LONG-TERM CARE FACILITIES TO
READMIT PATIENTS THAT HAD
COVID-19.
MANY OF THE CENTERS WERE
SCREAMING, THEY ARE NOT EQUIPPED
TO HANDLE THE CORONAVIRUS CASES.
THEY DIDN’T HAVE ANY PPE.
THE GOVERNOR SAID, WELL, THAT’S
NOT MY PROBLEM.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
NOT MY JOB, NOT HIS JOB TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH PPE.
SAME GUY THAT WAS SCREAMING, I
NEED 40,000 VENTILATORS.
MEANWHILE, THOUSANDS OF HOSPITAL
BEDS AT THE JAVITS CENTER THAT
THE PRESIDENT BUILT, THE
PRESIDENT STAFF, THE PRESIDENT
CONVERTED TO COVID-19 CAPABILITY
AND THE U.S. AND AS COMFORT, THE
HOSPITAL NAVY SHIP ALSO STAFFED
AND SENT BY THE PRESIDENT, AND
ALL THE PERSONNEL AND EQUIPMENT
THERE, COVID-19 CONVERTED.
WELL, THEY ONLY USED 182 OF
1,000 BEDS.
THEY ONLY USED A LITTLE OVER
1,000 OF THE 3,000 BEDS AT THE
JAVITS CENTER.
NEARLY A THIRD OF NEW YORK’S
CORONAVIRUS DEATHS CAME FROM
THIS BAD DECISION.
THAT’S 30,000, 30% OF OVER
27,000 PEOPLE DYING.
NOW CUOMO, FINALLY NEW YORK
MEDIA SEEMS TO HAVE CAUGHT UP TO
US, AND THEY ARE NOW ASKING HIM
A FEW TOUGH QUESTIONS.
HE SPENDING HIS DAYS PREPARING
HIS PERFECTLY, METICULOUSLY MADE
POWER POINTS, HE MADE THOSE BAD
DECISIONS.
NOW THEY ARE BEGINNING TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> UP UNTIL TODAY AS I AM BEFORE
YOU, I CAN LOOK YOU IN THE EYES
AND SAY WE DID EVERYTHING THAT
WE COULD.
AS A SOCIETY.
YOU CAN’T SAVE EVERYONE.
YOU’RE GOING TO LOSE PEOPLE.
THAT’S LIFE.
THAT’S -- SOMEBODY ELSE IS IN
CHARGE OF THAT APPEARED MUCH
HIGHER PAY GRADE.
BUT WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE SAME IS
TRUE UNTIL THIS IS OVER.
WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD.
>> Sean: THAT’S LIFE?
[LAUGHTER]
MENTION OF DONALD TRUMP -- WELL,
I TRIED MY BEST, THAT’S LIFE.
PEOPLE DIE.
CUOMO’S NURSING HOME MANDATE WAS
A DISASTER.
NOW, IT ALSO WAS DUPLICATED IN
OTHER BLUE STATES.
NOW REMEMBER, CUOMO PUT THAT
INTO EFFECT ON MARCH 25TH.
MARCH 29TH, THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA, THEY FOLLOWED
SUIT.
ON APRIL 9TH, THE STATE OF
NEW JERSEY, THEY WERE SENDING
COVID-19 PATIENTS INTO NURSING
HOMES AND LONG-TERM CARE
FACILITIES.
MICHIGAN, ALSO IMPLEMENTING
OTHER DUMB MEASURES BUT THEY
WOULDN’T LET YOU CUT YOUR LAWN
IN MICHIGAN.
ALL OF THESE STATES NOW ARE
FACING HORRIFIC DEATH TOLLS,
HORRIFIC INFECTION RATES.
AND AS I SAID, NEARLY 28,000
DEAD IN NEW YORK, NEARLY 10,000
IN NEW JERSEY.
LET’S LOOK AT FLORIDA.
A LITTLE OVER 1800.
TEXAS, DEATH TOLL UNDER 1200.
GEORGIA, UNDER 1500.
THOSE ARE ALL BIG STATES,
THEY’LL HAVE METROPOLITAN AREAS,
THEY ALL HAVE HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
ELDERLY POPULATION.
THEY DID SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD LEARN FROM, AND THAT IS
THEY TARGETED THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
PENNSYLVANIA AND MICHIGAN, THEY
BLEW IT.
THEY PUT THESE PEOPLE THAT WERE
MOST VULNERABLE IN THE WORST
POSITIONS.
NOW DO I THINK THEY DID IT
MALICIOUSLY OR ON PURPOSE?
NO, I JUST THINK THEY WERE DUMB.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IT WAS SO
DUMB IN NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY AND
PENNSYLVANIA, THEY COULD HAVE
TAKEN SOME OF THOSE EMPTY COVID
BEDS WITH TRUMP’S PERSONNEL,
TRUMP’S HOSPITALS BUILT AND SENT
THEM THERE BECAUSE THEY WERE
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
ON ANOTHER NOTE WE CAN ALSO
LEARN FROM BUSINESSES THAT NEVER
CLOSED DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
IMAGINE, I GO SHOPPING -- PEOPLE
ALWAYS ASK ME IN THE
GROCERY STORE, HANNITY, WHY ARE
YOU HERE?
SHOPPING, I LIKE TO EAT,
OBVIOUSLY.
THEY’RE LIKE, OH.
ANYWAY, I GET ASKED THAT
QUESTION.
BUT I TALKED ALL THE WORKERS.
I COME GROCERY’S JOB ONCE OR
TWICE A WEEK.
I WAS TALKED AT THE SAME GUY
THAT MY GROCERY STORES.
EVERY DAY STACKING THE SHELVES.
WE NEVER RAN OUT OF FOOD IN
NEW YORK OR LONG ISLAND.
THANKS TO THE PACKERS, THE
FARMERS COME ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THAT SUPPLY LINE, IF YOU LOOK AT
ALL THE MANUFACTURING PLANTS
THAT MADE ALL THE MASKS THAT
THEY NEEDED IN THE PPE AND THE
RESPIRATORS AND THE GLOVES, AND
THE GALLONS, AND THEY
NEVER STOPPED WORKING.
IF THEY SHUT DOWN A VERY THE
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN OR MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT CHAIN, NEW YORK WOULD
BE DEAD.
THEY DIDN’T SHUT DOWN, BUT
BECAUSE THEY WERE WEARING MASKS
IN THE EPICENTER, STOCKING THE
SHELVES IN NEW YORK, AND IN OUR
DRUG STORES IN NEW YORK AND
LONG ISLAND, PEOPLE LIVE.
WE CAN LEARN FROM THOSE LESSONS.
WE CAN LEARN FROM FLORIDA, WE
CAN LEARN FROM TEXAS, WE CAN
LEARN FROM GEORGIA.
AND THAT MEANS THAT PLACES LIKE
NEW YORK, L.A., YOU OUGHT TO
STAY LOCKED DOWN FOR MONTHS OR
EVEN YEARS.
WELL, YOUR CITIES WILL TURN INTO
GHOST TOWNS IN AMERICA’S
ECONOMY, YOUR ECONOMIES WILL
FACE PERMANENT DAMAGE.
STATES THAT ELECT SMARTER
GOVERNORS THAT DON’T TAX THEIR
CITIZENS TO DEATH AND ACTUALLY
PAY OFF THEIR PENSIONS AND DON’T
TAKE ON BIG DEBTS AND DEFICITS,
DON’T EXPECT THEM TO BAIL YOU
OUT BECAUSE THEY WON’T BE DOING
IT.
AS OF NOW, BY THE WAY, THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES JUST EXTENDED
THEIR RESTRICTIONS FOR THREE
MORE MONTHS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, NANCY PELOSI IS
QUITE PLEASED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WHO ARE
SAYING, WELL, THREE MORE MONTHS?
I CAN’T SURVIVE THIS IS A SMALL
BUSINESS, I CAN’T SURVIVE THIS
AS SOMEONE WHO IS OUT OF WORK.
>> OF COURSE I AGREE WITH THE
DECISIONS OF THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND AND THEIR PARTICULAR
VENUE AND LOCATION.
YES, IT’S INCONVENIENT, BUT IT’S
EVEN MORE INCONVENIENT IF YOU’RE
GOING TO BE INFECTED OR WORSE.
>> Sean: OKAY, NANCY PELOSI,
WE KNOW WHAT SHE’S UP TO.
SHE’S PLAYING POLITICS AS SHE
ALWAYS DOES.
IN FACT, SHE UNVEILED A MASSIVE
PROPOSAL.
NOTHING MORE THAN A GRAND
SOCIALIST WISH LIST WITH MONEY
FOR LEGAL IMMIGRANTS, MAIL-IN
VOTING MEASURES WITHOUT THE NEED
FOR I.D. OF ANY KIND, BANKING
PROTECTIONS FOR MARIJUANA
DISTRIBUTORS INTO TRILLION
DOLLAR BAILOUT FOR BLUE STATES
THAT MISAPPROPRIATE YOUR
HARD-EARNED TAX DOLLARS.
SHE WANTS TO TAKE YOUR MONEY,
TAKE THE MONEY FROM FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE RED STATES AND
REDISTRIBUTE THEM TO STATES THAT
HAVE MORE WASTE, FRAUD, AND
ABUSE THAN YOU COULD EVER
IMAGINE.
NATURE
TO MIKE NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
CALIFORNIA.
SO THEY CAN BREAK YOUR BUDGETS
AND START SPENDING AGAIN.
THEY WANT TO PAY OFF THE INSANE
BUDGETS AND ENERGY PROGRAMS,
THREE OF THEM FAILED IN
NEW YORK.
$1,750,000,000, $190 MILLION.
THE ENTITLEMENTS ARE LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, RED STATES SHOULDN’T
HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT EITHER, SO
LET ME BE CLEAR, NO STATE
BAILOUT -- AS A MATTER FACT,
WASHINGTON, FOR CLOSE ATTENTION.
HE SPENT ENOUGH MONEY.
NO MORE SPENDING, WE NEED MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
TRILLIONS OF LOANS AVAILABLE,
THAT’S A LOT OF MONEY.
LET’S SEE HOW IT GOES AND DO
YOUR BEST TO OPEN THE COUNTRY
SAFELY.
LEARN FROM FLORIDA, TEXAS,
GEORGIA, AND LEARN FROM THE GUYS
WHO WERE STOCKING THE
GROCERY STORE SHELVES WHERE I
LIVE THAT WERE MASKS AND GLOVES
AND THEY NEVER GOT SICK.
NONE OF THEM.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW USING THIS
VIRUS AS A POLITICAL WEAPON.
PRESIDENT RIGHTLY CALLING THEM
OUT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE REPORT, THEY ARE DYING
WITH THIS CLOSURE, THIS SHUTDOWN
OF A COUNTRY WHERE THEY ARE IN
THEIR HOUSE OR IN THEIR
APARTMENT.
THEY’RE NOT ALLOWED -- SOME
PEOPLE ARE TOO TOUGH ON IT.
THEY’RE NOT ALLOWED TO GO OUT.
THEY’RE LOSING THEIR JOBS.
WERE NOT GOING TO LET IT HAPPEN.
>> DO YOU THINK YOUR CRITICS
WANT YOU TO KEEP IT CLOSED GOING
INTO THE ELECTION?
>> YEAH, I DO, I DO.
I THINK IT’S A POLITICAL THING
IN ADDITION --
>> THEY SAY YOU’RE PUTTING MONEY
AND BUSINESS AHEAD OF LIVES.
>> NOTE -- I THINK, THE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SEE THE RIGHT THING
HAPPEN, THEY AGREE WITH ME.
WE HAVE TO GET OUR COUNTRY OPEN.
>> Sean: GOT TO GET THE
COUNTRY OPEN.
BY THE WAY, THOSE MEDICAL SUPPLY
MANUFACTURERS, THEY NEVER
CLOSED.
IF THEY DID, WE WERE DONE.
IF ANY FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN BROKE
IN ANY CAPACITY, NEW YORK IS
DONE.
WE WOULD’VE STARVED TO DEATH.